nothing that fury
in the recharging
Dave as you know I'm a huge fan of devil
and the evils yeah that's that's the
first thing I learned about you yeah
which means I like Diablo quite a bit
Diablo 3 is a game that I've spent many
many hours playing as well as previous
entries in the series so when they
announce his coming to switch I was very
very excited then last week
Blizzard for an actual chest a huge
chest now I've played full of loot many
many hundreds of hours of overwatch and
I can tell you it feels so good to
finally open a loop box from Blizzard
thank you good of it poppin shady you
never get any good as area skins they're
put goods or skins in the game in Diablo
but this chest had four switches in it
with Diablo the final build of Diablo
and we played it together and you played
it as well yep recently and it's it's
weird because the most exciting thing
about it is that it's Diablo yeah like
they haven't really needed to change
much to really make it shine on switch
which probably speaks more to the hablo
than really say anything else it's it
works amazingly on switch yeah I mean
they're awesome
from like a fundamental perspective like
the game is as it should be it's it's a
good representation of the the the other
versions of Diablo in terms of the
gameplay it's got all the same quality
of life stuff that you they had to win
the with the console versions a quick
inventory stuff like radio manual menus
look really good like I've played I
played it mostly on PC this is really
the most I've spent with it on a console
version and I find it was like again
super easy to just get like your head
around the way everything worked
yeah and it's feature-rich as well it's
got the seasoned stuff in it it's got
online play local play it's got the
Reaper of souls expansion it's got the
extra classes yeah and next month's room
yeah and it feels that there are the
only obvious things that stand out to me
is it doesn't look as good as it I mean
it's not going to right yeah and so
that's like having said that it's only
really noticeable when you're playing
handheld I found like you can tell it's
it's like a lower resolution
version of a everything's not as sharp
looking and at times it can be a bit
tricky to kind of keep track of the
action almost especially when you've got
a bunch of players together yeah we're
like full play on a smaller screen but
when I was playing I thought I'm I'm I'm
happy that they've made small sacrifices
here and there to keep the feeling of
Diablo true like I would rather
sacrifice in graphics say you keep loads
of mobs on the screen to keep all the
abilities and all the effects like
really bright and colorful I want that
I'd much prefer that than have like
super fidelity barbarian yeah so we
played like fairly early we started from
the beginning of the game and yeah it's
just after rescuing Deckard Cain yeah so
and they have like in that first few
hours they have a few like large mugs
and there wasn't any kind of performance
hits or anything like that in Evo
version standard or handheld or docked
yeah so and like you said I think that's
an important part of it like it might
look slightly worse when you're playing
in handheld but that doesn't reduce the
underlying satisfaction you get running
into it it's the feeling of Diablo you
one you don't like as Diablo is great
but you're not jumping into Diablo for
the look right you're jumping in for the
feeling it gets you like that loot chase
all those mobs in the satisfaction of
crunching them all with like massive
attacks at the moment you've dock it it
looks great again yeah a big screen and
and you know you can follow everything
and it all plays really well I think
that's the most dangerous part of it
it's like to me I feel like it's been a
long time since we've called the game
day names
I mean Diablo is a dangerous series and
most Blizzard games are dangerous to me
yeah but like I think that's that's the
most appealing part of it having like
this kind of two-part experience where
the when I have it docked and I'm
playing in a big big screen I'm also
checked very likely gonna be connected
to Wi-Fi and and be able to play with
friends and that kind of stuff so like I
feel like I'll get the big kind of
overall the broader proper Diablo
experience when docked but if I take it
off on handheld that's kind of like my
permission to grind and use my off off
moments to you know Lou chase and it
almost feels like we're cheating a bit
by living in like a city because we have
a commute and we have like the London
Underground that gives you an
opportunity to play like a perfect
bite-sized chunk of Diablo like chase
another piece of Lou
do a little grinding but like people
that don't get that I feel it almost
missing out because they're if they're
more online all the time or they don't
have the opportunity to just see it on
like a tube carriage and escape the
world for 30 minutes yeah that's a
perfect Diablo time yeah it's the
world's gifting us Diablo time now yeah
that's that's the most exciting part of
it and then like I'm accepting I loves
playing the hablo but I played it very I
in an isolationist function on both PC
I've had it so - yeah but like I'm
actually excited about the idea of
playing with people on the big screen
and then telling everyone all right
let's go away we'll meet back in two or
three days or tomorrow and make sure you
grind a bunch and and we'll see we'll
come back together and progress further
so that is the most exciting part of it
and like I've got it's a game that I
really want to play with other people
now before I was like I just want the
atmosphere of it and I'm kind of amazed
myself I want to immerse myself now I'm
like oh it feels like I can I played it
through a bunch of times yeah played a
bunch of it so I feel like I can have
more of a communal experience and the
switch just happens to be the perfect
way to do that yeah the way the
multiplayer works was was super cool
just the fact that like I've never added
anyone on my Nintendo friends I've never
point a friend you know because I hate
that system real bad but we were just on
the same Wi-Fi and Diablo was like hey
these other nerds are on this Wi-Fi
account playing Diablo to do so do you
want to join them so just going down the
pub with your mates putting out a few
switches varnishing not completely
ignoring each other and crunching some
mobs for 30 minutes is like it's great
just the way it works it needs to be
it's one of the games it needs to be
seamless if there's the more faff they
have the less attractive it is to just
go and like chase a quest with your
friends so it needs to just be like
snappy quick dropping it out the other
thing I know there's a lot of like the
Blizzard community is very large and
vocal and and like every time I get
weird about having the other and playing
Diablo last week and a lot of responses
were like oh it's just the same game
we've been playing for ages Skyrim and
that yeah it's like that sounds like
it's what why is that a bad thing yeah
it's a really good game and now it's on
switch I can appreciate that there's a
there's an element of people wanting new
Diablo stuff and Blizzard
said that's happening but that's I got
the base like Diablo experienced in the
palm of my hand and I'm excited about it
and it's that arguing right where the
people who were working on making Diablo
3 on switch like the top pulling
resources they're a separate team yeah
like you you could you can have both
yeah you can afford to be greedy in this
instance like little lizards literally
giving you your cake and you're like
yeah yeah I'm excited to play more of it
I just wanna I'm looking forward to
integrating that into my lifestyle now
that's let's see I know you well enough
that you saying I'm looking forward to
integrating Diablo into your lifestyle
means you're going to play on a toilet
exactly my dead cells also my dead cells
time is on the pooper I'm gonna laugh
poo follicles on mice which are abundant
that's the highest praise we give the
other thing I think that yeah that puts
a nice nail in the coffin in this
conversation
well I guess for everything else do I
blow three and anything else call the
blizzards doing they can hit opportunity
games for all your toilet updates and
Diablo where can they find you I'm at
two Moorhead you're on Twitter I'm at a
regular day if I promise I won't talk
about any of that sort of Filth don't
act like one you don't who - don't play
games in the toilet yeah now you're
right it's disgusting